Generally, I would say that most computer scientist believe that P does not equal NP
and there are basically two reasons for that.
The first reason is the power of nondeterminism. The power of guessing correctly.
It kind of seems strange that should be possible always on polynomial time
and the second reason and unfortunately we'll only briefly touch that in this course
is that there are problems that are believe to be even much harder than NP complete problems and
P=NP will imply that also this much harder problems would be solvable in polynomial time.
The high chances that P does not equal NP is of course what makes
resolving the P versus NP question much harder
because if we want to do show that P=NP
then all we would have to find is one single polynomial time algorithm
for an NP complete problem but if we want to show that P does not equal NP
then we'll have to construct some mathematical proof
that takes into account any conceivable algorithm
no matter how sophisticated or thoughtful or advanced
as long as that algorithm runs in polynomial time, we must show
that it cannot solve an NP complete problem.
Now as famous as the P versus NP question is there is some heated debate
on whether that would actually have any practical consequences.
On theoretical level of course, it would be a fantastic result
and the person who manages to resolve P versus NP would become quite famous
but on a practical level there is two things to consider.
One is that polynomial time doesn't always mean efficiency.
So as we have seen, that the NP completeness proof of SAT,
the polynomials involved quickly get very large and of course a polynomial time algorithm with a time of
say n²⁰ would not really be practical, and on the other hand
because NP complete problems are so important in practice,
there's lots of techniques that have been developed to actually deal with them
and we'll learn some of them in this course of course.
In any case if you want to spark a heated debate between theoretical computer scientist
should you ever have the opportunity to do so then just ask them
whether resolving P versus NP would have any practical consequences.